greg's with us in uh california hi greg
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey thank you for taking my call sure
what's up so um
my beginner pandemic my wife lost her
job
and then i was put on reduced pay in
hours
um and throughout the
season we've been able to save money and
get to about 30 000 saved
however we do have a 15 000 401k loan
and what we're trying to do because
we're kind of hesitant to pay it
mainly because my job they just
furloughed more general managers
but i was one of the ones that wasn't so
we're trying to determine if
we're holding back because we're more
fearful or should we pay it
to get rid of that debt even though we
have a risk as my job may be gone
well how real is that risk greg like uh
how
yeah i mean is it something that can
happen in the next few months
well they're telling us they're
confident i'm a movie theater general
manager
so they're confident that we'll
eventually reopen
we just don't know when right so in
california
right especially in california well
here's here's why i'm asking this i feel
you your resume needs to get out
and be dusted up and prepared because
here's the downside
with the 401k loan if you do lose that
job
you'll have 60 to 90 days before that
401k loan is due and payable
correct so mindset wise if i'm you
i would be dusting off my resume to
really start to look like
yeah why is your wife looking for work
as well she found something
um no we had her not look because our
children have some
therapies and some health issues that
have required her to really focus on
them
while my schedule is actually beefed up
on time
because i travel a lot more to watch
other theaters
okay so you're more of a regional
manager type at this stage is that what
you're saying
you have more more than one theater is
that what you're saying
yeah only because right now they
furloughed a lot of the general manager
as well
having one gm multi-check multiples here
okay but you're really just looking at
closed buildings right now right oh
absolutely yes oh lord
i'm sorry oh what a disaster
um yeah i i think i'm with chris i
you know here's the thing you stop
all baby steps push pause and pile up
cash
if a storm is coming now we have to
define and that's what chris and i are
doing talking to you is trying to find
how what's the probability that this
hurricane is going to affect your home
okay if i'm in nashville and it's going
to hit new orleans i'm probably going to
be okay
right but in your case you got you got
winds coming right at you it sounds like
number one you're in an industry that's
really struggling
uh and it's going to struggle with covid
more than a lot of other industries i
mean like a live event type setting i
mean it's a
this is a very difficult thing to reopen
um and number two you're in freaking
california which has completely lost its
mind
and so um and
you know politically you've got all
kinds of problems
in terms of reopening and so if i'm you
i'm pretty scared for my job
so no i wouldn't pay that off today i'd
pile up cash as high as you can pilot i
would have everybody working that could
work
and let's really get the plywood over
the windows and
all of you be looking for jobs and all
of you get your resumes dusted off
and all of you have a plan for if this
doesn't go well
now if the storm passes
and it wasn't a direct hit we take the
plywood off the windows and we start
again right
okay but right now i i don't i don't see
that storm passing in the next six
months in your setting or three months
anyway
yeah i could be wrong i mean maybe they
recall newsome and they open up the
whole state but i
doubt it i don't i don't i don't know
anything about it i'm just watching from
the outside like everybody else going oh
my goodness what a mess
and so um yeah uh
well and dave like you said the piling
up cash
let's talk there's no doubt there's not
a downside to it and here's the deal
this wasn't found money like that the
plan is is when the storm passes
you then unpause and keep working the
steps pay it off
immediately yeah so you know once you
are secure in your job that's right
and or the new job right you pay off
that 401k loan immediately with the cash
is laying there and you push play again
and you go finish your baby steps that's
right you're good point chris oh that's
the main thing you want to do it is it
really is take care of the four walls
food shelter clothing transportation
utility polyp cash right
be ready for the big bad wolf to huff
and puff right mean third be the third
pig in the brick house right
get the four walls built and then go
from there
and and so the big bad wolf wanders off
now we can come back out we can do
you know the shutters are open we can be
back out in the sunshine
we can do stuff again and um got to
reevaluate you poor folks man i'm so
sorry for you
i mean we don't have i don't think we
have theaters open here do we no yeah i
think we did
oh there we did they probably just
closed them again right i don't know i
can't keep up with what they're doing
but
it's like i mean it's a it's an industry
that was in trouble anyway netflix is
destroying them
yeah and so they were hurting already
and then they just
politically just finished rushed a great
american icon
the movie theater this is the dave
ramsey show